يبدو ان الانتخابات رياضيه الامريكيه
ستحظى بترقب غير مسبوق من طرف الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين فنتائجها قد تغير
مجرى الحرب بشكل كلي سيابا في حال فوز احد
المرشحين الرئيسيين للحزب الجمهوري دونالد
ترامبس فكلاهما غير مؤيد للحرب بالاساس
ترامب نفسه كان واضحا بخصوص موقفه من
الحرب حيث قال انه سينهيها في غضون 24
ساعه اذا تولى رئاسه الولايات المتحده اما
ديسانتس فاوضح ان المزيد من التورط في
نزاع اقليمي بين روسيا واوكرانيا ليس في
مصلحه الولايات المتحده هذا وتفيد
استطلاعات لصحيفه فاينالشي عند موقف
الناخبين الجمهوريين بدات تتجهوا نحو
مناهضه الحرب فاقل من 40% فقط يؤيدون
استمرار واشنطن في تزويد كييف بالاسلحه
ولا شك ان موقف الجمهوريين من الدعم
الامريكي لاوكرانيا في الحرب يبدو اقل
تاييدا قياسا بموقف الديمقراطيين فمن
المرتقب ان تنفذ واشنطن خلال الخريف
المقبل تموينا الى اوكرانيا بقيمه 45
مليار دولار كان اقره الكونجرس في ديسمبر
وهي الحزمه التي لم ترقى كثيرا او لم ترق
كثيرا للجمهوريين حينها حضر كيفن مكافي
الرئيس الجمهوري لمجلس النواب من تقديم
شركات على بياض لاوكرانيا ونقل عن صحيفه
يمني نفسه في فوز الجمهوريين حيث يتوقع ان
تجف بعدها امدادات امريكا من المال
والاسلحه الى اوكرانيا ومن المرجح ان يكون
الملف الحرب في اوكرانيا مؤثرا في
اختيارات داخلين الامريكيين
المنقسمين بين راغب في مواصله بلاده دعم
اوكرانيا واخر يفضل وضع حد للحرب بعد
الازمات الاقتصاديه الخانقه التي تسببت
بها